when we started getting all that money
funneling into the country after the end
of World War two and the Social
Democrats were like look at us how good
socialism is working yes and it had
nothing to do with them in fact their
policies big government policies wasted
all that money and you know in the 1990s
we actually had to devaluate our
currency against the 30% of everything
was lost because of the welfare state
they built up this is the Rubin report
and I'm once again Dave Rubin here's a
friendly reminder to subscribe to our
channel by clicking that pesky bell and
turning on notifications so that you
might just might see our videos and more
importantly joining me today are two
Swedish podcast Superstars and free
speech activists in no order Aaron flem
and Henrik Johnson welcome to the Rubin
report thank you for having us
I am glad to have you guys we have sat
down before yes what years ago a couple
years ago before I do anything else did
I give proper Swedish pronunciation of
the names there that could that was a
very American version of 10 out of 10
yeah I'm fine with however you say my
name is jung sung-ryong song so I
purposely did that so I said so if you
were saying Aaron flam in perfect
Swedish how would you say autumn Flum
okay there we go
and I said henrik johnson but i knew it
was a little more off with you yeah
henrik eunsung that's the way you say
this but you know I lived in London for
10 years so I almost changed my name to
Johnson because the nightmare of
explaining this bizarre pronunciation
just and also the Oh would to adults on
top of it Oh with the two dots and I
knew that the J was really a why in our
world but I wanted you to say it first
so it sounded a little a little smoother
anyway
I'm thrilled to have you guys here I'll
preface all of this by saying something
that I told you guys earlier in the week
when I did both of your podcasts which
is that bizarrely almost impossibly our
5th most watched country for this show
the Rubin report is Sweden so it's the
United States first and then usually
Canada and the UK battle out to and
three and then Australia is four and
then Sweden even though we only have ten
million people I have half the
population of Sweden in this room right
now and somehow whatever it is that
we're talking about here related to free
speech and the rest of it has really hit
a nerve in Sweden I also think it's
partly because I had you on and that
that show really just exploded I've
since done a couple shows in in Sweden
with Jordan Peterson so before we do
anything else and I'll go to you first I
just tell my audience a little bit about
yourself tell me a little bit about
yourself and what you do and all that
good stuff and then we'll recap with you
and then we'll take it from there
well my background I'm really a
businessman I'm an IT IT entrepreneur I
built a number of companies over the
years but about two years ago I recorded
a small YouTube video well actually a
facebook video on my phone
where I out of spite I was irritated
with the journalistic
journalists establishments incapacity of
correctly describing the difference
between dividends and a profit in a
private company because we had this big
debate about how we didn't want
commercial companies in the healthcare
sector so I made a video where I said
okay listen guys if you want to talk
about this you need to understand the
difference between those two different
singing now I'm gonna tell you all so I
posted it on Facebook morning after I
woke up my mailbox was overflowing and
it so many people just going why you're
so good at explaining of this stuff
nobody ever talks about this and then I
started making videos now I run the
largest politically minded YouTube
channel in Sweden should I ask what
level of hate you got just by putting
out a video about dividends and health
insurance the market well you know that
was a sort of neutral video because it
was on taxation but let's put a
dissertation often is not neutral at
least in this country but maybe it's a
little more neutral for you guys because
you've been numbed into well taxation is
like air for us but did you get a lot of
haters I guess you didn't initially very
little because the situation we have
back home is like the left does not
follow people like me because I'm you
know I have a business background they
think well he's a capitalist Pig so
let's not listen to this guy yeah but
my channel grew and now I have about
600,000 people a month watching my
videos which is more than most of the
national newspapers have so then I
become a problem so now I am getting
quite a bit of flack just you know just
being on your show is probably gonna
push a few people's buttons we're gonna
quadruple your flack today Aaron I
obviously I know a little more about
your story but for the people that did
not see our first well they should know
because they should have watched every
episode sure most I'm a Swedish comedian
and then after a while I realized I
can't do my jokes anymore my beautifully
constructed child pornography jokes and
then well we don't exactly have free
speech in Sweden we got it in 94 from
the EU and that's sort of but I I would
like to have some in Sweden so I've been
working at that since last we met and
since we met last I've been doing very
little comedy although I have done some
comedy
yeah because yes at the LA improv and it
went quite well they loved my abortion
jokes and so and then since last we met
because I at the point when we met I
want to define like the route course of
the craziness that is going on in the
Western world right now and you've
written a book about it and I just
finished and published my book about it
unfortunately in Swedish but I'll get
you an English version I want the
English version because yes not only do
I not speak Swedish but your book we
should have had it on the table here
I'll have my guys grab it it's about how
many pages almost 500 pages right and
this thing is dense I mean you could if
you whacked somebody with this thing
it's like a brick yes I won't yeah I
want everything I do to be able to be
used in multiple ways but no it's cold
this is a Swedish tiger and basically
it's I I got proof that the Socialists
and the Islamists has have pretty much
been working together since the end of
world war true and that the Socialists
didn't turn in 43 but they were in
Hitler's side until the end and after
the war they sort of swept that under
the carpet found alliances because the
Islamists were what turned morphed into
the Islamists
were on Hitler side as well and they
continued that alliance and I think
we're seeing the endpoint of that
cooperation now so it's a comedy well
it's a very dark comedy like almost
everything these days
so you start doing video pipe did you
start doing video first video right
video yeah um so you start doing the
video and just by talking about these
things my sense from what's going on in
Sweden is that there's just a lot of
people due to cultural reasons that
hopefully you guys can explain just
don't really say what they're thinking
enough yes and then it makes guys like
you very unique a comedian it's one
thing to be doing it but a guy from a
business background were you shocked yes
yes I was yeah listen I think part of
the reason that your show is popular in
Sweden is our nation it's like the
canary in the coal mine and people are
like so penned up because we have a
highly like a fiercely egalitarian
culture it's very conformist so it's
incredibly threatening to break the mold
but there is this pent-up need of you
know seriously engaging in open
conversation about a lot of issues that
are well they put the lid on those and I
think that that's what you were picking
up on what when you went there and I
think that is why once once I started
making my videos it just exploded
because there were so many people well
how do you do you know say these things
what were the first couple of type of
things that you were talking about well
here's where Aaron and I kind of connect
because I wanted to debunk the idea that
the social democratic rule which has
been running Sweden for the better part
of the last hundred years
they took credit for the financial
miracle that we had basically Sweden
rose from rather poor agrarian economy
into like the per capita wealthiest
country on earth over a couple of
decades but that was mainly doing if you
ask economists they will know this but
nobody speaks about it the reason that
happened was because we did not take a
stand against the Nazis in the war so we
actually sold them iron ore and granite
and after the war we were also the only
intact manufacturing industrialised
manufacturer
nation in Europe so we exported
everything to everyone and that's all we
became rich so you see you were acting
like capitalists sort of on the DL on
the down-low but in effect I'd say no
that's the the worst brand of crony
capitalism I would say yeah what about
you when so you were doing stand-up
first but what were the issues first
that you were talking about that you
realized shouldn't be talking about as a
comedian I know what cultural taboos we
have so I just made a list and you know
started doing jokes on every cultural
taboo because that was my job so I went
through you know the usual shock thing
you can always do a pedophilia joke
because you know or fisting joke it's
funny but then I said drugs marijuana
family show so and then I went to
marijuana and but when I've never
experienced as much hate as when I
started my campaign to crush socialism
mm-hmm
because in their minds that's just the
most taboo thing you could ever say
that's the entire system you're you know
you're basically [ __ ] where you eat
so when you say you don't have free
speech in Sweden what does that actually
mean well you are free to say whatever
you want as long as no one takes offence
or gets insulted because what's gonna
happen if someone takes offense or gets
it's all because we're now we're
commemorating this idea yes because then
their feelings are hurt and if you want
to have a socialist welfare state
everyone has to be like cogs in the
wheel so that's why you need conformism
and collectivism and a culture of
silence and that is why they get so
annoyed when he speaks out because he's
breaking the culture of silence and
cultures of silence are about
maintaining the real because as long as
everyone has the same lie then that's
reality but if someone says wait a
minute this might not be exactly the
case like for instance Henrik got
burglarized in mama where he lives I
don't know if told you that yes I do
want to talk about that yeah so and then
when he talks about that he breaks the
culture of silence that Sweden is
peaceful it
is ordered everything works no one needs
a gun for self-defense because the
police where the state will take care of
everything and and remarkably enough
that's the reason why my book by the way
is called this is a Swedish tiger
because tiger in Swedish means both the
apex predator and shut up so during the
Second World War there was a campaign in
Sweden launched by the government that
said be a Swedish tiger which means be
silent but deadly it's very clever and
very Orwellian I'd like to add two
things what you just said I mean
formally you're allowed to say anything
you want in Sweden yeah yeah but the
consequences of doing so can be very
very severe people will hate you and
they will sometimes go after who your
employer they will try to make it
impossible for you to work so it is the
culture of silence yeah and it's it's
very aggressive but we never speak of it
the other which is but the second thing
that I think is important to mention
there it's like like the establishment
media of Sweden it's everything you know
the news organizations and so forth they
have been losing a lot of their revenue
to you know the digital tech gotten
giants like Google or Facebook and so
forth and very unhappy about that so
they've been pushing the government to
intervene with what they're doing are
under the guise of well you know it's
promoting extremism or whatever people
are writing nasty things on Facebook
yeah and they pushed it all the way to
the top government so the Minister of
Justice actually had a meeting with
Google and Facebook this is it you can
read this in the papers I can send you
links for this or he actually told them
well of course there's freedom of speech
and it's great that your private
companies and private companies make
their own decisions is that sort of
putting like your guess about your
private but we think you should clean up
some of the stuff on your platforms
otherwise we might have to move forward
with regulation now I wouldn't want to
be you know the president of Facebook
suite and having to answer to you on
American CEOs
tell them that I'm the guy that made him
regulate our company mm-hmm so so what
type of slurs have been thrown at you
guys because that seems to be what it
boil down you haven't been dragged off
to jail right so when we talk about free
speech it's not they haven't jailed you
yet but what type of slurs are they
throwing at you to make sure that it
perhaps hampers some of your businesses
or hampers your ability to perform at
clubs or five or six days ago they
called us hoarse venmo wars venmo [ __ ]
who's they in this case well that would
be product that this is this was
actually a text written by a rather
famous establishment journalist in one
of the biggest national papers right who
had a big issue so in fact he works for
a state-run paper but because no no no
here's the thing
so they call they call these papers and
media outlets free media right but they
are they're all on the take as you would
call it or subsidized as we would call
it this game is actually on Swedish
radio so I have the recording downloaded
where he
yeah that's state radio actually put on
state radio so in a he's funded by the
state to get this message out there
called you guys independent people
putting stuff up on YouTube he likened
us to proselytize
our venmo this is now this is grifter
right this is the one that would get to
thrown at us in America all right he
tried it you know it's like if I was
grifting I would be doing the other
thing right what would if we were
grifters what would be the easiest thing
to do work for NPR I in socialism buy
into yeah from you yeah they want to
turn you into us yeah I told you last
time we want you to assimilate okay so
that's exactly where I wanted to go with
this because if you listen to our
socialist Democrats or Democratic
socialists or whatever the hell they are
these days I keep saying they're gonna
drop the Democrat part soon enough what
they always say is we should be more
like Sweden aoc says this Bernie says
this I doubt that AOC has ever been to
Sweden perhaps Bernie has been to Sweden
but they say the Nordic countries
usually but it's specifically we should
be more like Sweden
you guys have 10 million people we have
350 million people we have people from
every walk of life from every corner of
the earth you guys mainly were a
homogenous society into the last couple
years there's all sorts of reasons that
that analogy doesn't quite make sense
but when you hear that America should be
more like Sweden well what is that
nothing pushes my buttons then when I
hear stuff like that you know this comes
out of the mouths of what Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren let's clear this up
once and for all
Sweden was never a socialist country in
the sense that the Eastern Bloc was you
know Soviet you know so forth when
Sweden became wealthy this was during
the the last part of the 1800s we had a
bunch of lessee fare reforms done so we
that's when we started a transformation
to industrialize we were actually quite
late to the game it was this you know
market free-market reforms that when you
got the government out lazy yes suddenly
the economy starts booming okay you um
August Gibbons death is the name of the
guy that was very forward-thinking and
that that made these reforms possible
and then things started getting better
yeah but better after that the other
thing you need to remember is that when
when we started getting all that money
funneling into the country after the end
of World War two and the Social
Democrats were like look at us how good
socialism is working yes and it had
nothing to do with them in fact their
policies big government policies wasted
all that money and you know in the 1990s
we actually had to devaluate our
currency against all right 30 percent of
everything was lost because of the
welfare state they built up so if you
hear Bernie Sanders or Warren say stuff
like we need to be more like Sweden well
the part they're missing is that what
was good about Sweden was free market
oriented what was bad about Sweden we
turned out into a decent country in
spite of socialism not because of can
you add to that I can confirm that if
that is true and you can look it up it's
factual yeah so when you guys hear that
and doing what you were
I mean it just makes your head spin sort
of
you're gonna smack somebody well I love
my job I really do because I get to piss
people off and I believe what Larry
David once said that if you have the
opportunity to annoy someone you should
take it yeah well you are doing now
you're doing just fine it what do you
think part of the issue here is that the
exterior of Sweden looks a certain way
so for example I had two trips to Sweden
to Stockholm and I was only in Stockholm
so what I'm seeing is a very snapshot
version but just from walking around
Stockholm or maybe what we see in the
media if or in the movies if they show
for us someone from Sweden they're
always very tall they look very good you
know they're they're blond like you and
they're in Nice jackets and what I
notice from walking around in Stockholm
was it looked like everyone bought their
clothes that morning everyone looked
fantastic
they everything was clean the streets
were clean all those things now I get it
it's a very small little micro version
of this but is that part of the problem
that the veneer of this somehow is still
selling well or something like that
outside of your borders absolutely I
think it's sort of a Potemkin village if
you know is that it's a backdrop and
behind it well it reminds me of
Hollywood that way yeah right yeah if
you look at it in front it looks good
but if you look behind the curtain you
but you don't hide you're homeless we
would hide them yeah now we can't afford
to hide them anymore well we can't hide
them anymore because you're here in
California where they're pretty much
everywhere I have I have noticed yeah so
no but I think just like not speaking
out against things you might see as
wrong or incorrect it is very important
that everything looks good if you are to
have a culture of silence and a quasi
socialist state how are you guys able to
gauge how much effect you're actually
having on the average Swede I'd say
judging by the reactions we're getting
from our enemies things are going very
well yeah they get very upset you know
funnily enough like the extreme left
people they usually do not touch
it is the social liberals who are you
know it's supposed to be like
center-right can you explain a little
bit how what the differentiation there
is for an American perspective because I
think Americans here that the social
liberals and the far-left that sounds
sort of like the same of course yes
liberal here means a lefty whereas in
Europe the word liberal is moving that
direction in Europe as well but it still
means more like the classical Austrian
liberalism I'm a European liberal Yeah
right perfect yeah me too that's I I
would use the word you know fiscally
conservative but socially liberal to
describe myself so that's where most of
the attacks are coming from on my end
you know from journalists you know
people of platform establishment media
platforms they will be very upset and
they will find a single word that I
don't like in a sentence pull it out and
start a tweet storm of you know they
will tell you things like what you're
dangerous you're a populistic alarmist
you're not taking responsibility for
what kind of people you take on your to
your show and you know going back to
this thing with a canary in the coal
mine this is the thing because oh what
all of these people have been doing is
working so very very hard at guiding the
population to the correct moral
standpoint at the end of whatever they
produce and well you don't do that you
bring somebody else on the show say okay
this is a completely different
perspective and I'm not going to attack
you I I don't want to fight you I want
to explore your idea and just see what I
make of it they hate it they do not want
it yeah is there anyone politically that
is echoing some of your sentiments about
what's happening in Sweden well Hanif
Bali does the job from time to time when
it his party doesn't try to rein him in
with rowdy he's part of the moderate
party which was right-wing that would be
by American standards that would be like
like lists well what like what type of
policies would they have judge just
because I'm trying to get the matter
lower taxes more personal responsibility
and individual choice they're trying to
get it in there but basically be a
like like yeah I think they call
themselves liberal conservatives liberal
conservative yeah that sort of made that
yeah Jag's with me I suppose so I told
you guys that when I was in Stockholm
for the two shows with Jordan Peterson
and I saw you there that they really
stuck out well first off I was
particularly excited about them because
I knew that this small country was my
fifth most watched country and I was
like what the hell's going on here so I
sort of had Jordan also knew that a huge
percentage of his viewership was from
there so we both sort of had that date
that first Stockholm date in our minds
as something special is happening this
shows were incredible the first show
sold out literally in a minute which is
why we added the second show the
audiences were were phenomenal correct
me if I'm you were so popular there was
a black market trading in tickets to
your shows I would like to say that it
was Jordan that was very popular so just
for the record but the thing that that
truly struck me was that after the show
we would do our meet and greets and
Jordan would meet with hundreds of
people mine we would just quickly sell
them basically right before the show so
I usually get you know 30 or 40 people
because we have to do it very quick but
at the the to Stockholm shows we had
about eighty or a hundred people we
jammed all of these people into a small
room we're sitting there and it felt
like something memorable to me it felt
everyone in the day had prepared
question for you and they had prepared
for you everyone in that room had
something written down or something on
their phone or something they wanted to
hand to me or that I should read or a
story or something and it was it was so
moving to me that I think I said to you
is there a bar around here we can go to
and we took everybody and we went to a
bar and we hung out for hours and I met
until they took it until they close they
came to us out and I met some of the
Swedish intellectuals that you guys hang
out with literally people I know have
not even asking a question here suffice
to say that it was so obvious to me that
something is from having like an a
disproportionate amount of viewers for
such a small country of your show and
Jordans videos
well you caused quite a splash so can
you Minister our foreign minister of
foreign affairs yeah well
publicly as said Jordan Peterson is a
bargain should crawl back under the rock
he came from yes which I was able to
quote her at the beginning of the show
and it got quite a laugh everyone
basically screamed the end of the joke
before I well yes she she just retired
thank God
you can't buy PR like that yeah but what
do you make of that sort of thing so
when you when you know the ideas that
Jordan said so so let me just explain
our Minister of Foreign Affairs she goes
to Iran yeah she goes to all these
places and does business as one should
with dictators or whatever or not so she
meets truly horrible people in the net
in her work and that's what's so funny I
mean this is just a Canadian professor
of psychology who tells people to make
their beds in the middle and she's never
voiced anything negative about the
Iranian regime or yeah so it's it's
quite you know it's funny not funny it's
an I suppose depressing in a certain
level that she said that after our first
show so then I think we had a day or two
away I think maybe we were now at
Copenhagen or somewhere else and I
remember thinking when we were coming
back that you know we're going through
security again were going through the
border again and I were thinking you
know we just saw this story I think we
saw it on the plane what the what the
Foreign Minister said like but why
wouldn't they stop us at the border or
harass him or whatever us no they didn't
but that sort of thing it's like we can
sort of joke about it now and it sounds
so ridiculous but there is another human
element to it that is but you you came
in and just coming in is breaking a
culture of silence so they have to do
something they have to tell their
listeners don't listen to these guys
they are here to destroy us you know and
I mean the story you're telling about
how old these people had written down
questions for you to me that's actually
it's so it's a beautiful thing that it
almost brings tears to my eyes literally
almost brought tears to my eyes because
you know I get all these emails from
like young guys who want to you know
begin exploring their lives and they
they are thirst
for you know an open discussion and the
fact that Mara got bounced on the you
know the minister that told Jordan to
crawl under a rock that is like the
perfect example of the culture of
silence that we have because the fact
that he just showed up in Sweden you
know they had to make a stand that this
is what this man is saying it's not part
of the narrative that we want here yes
can you talk about how this is related
to sort of how men are treated or at
least talked about in Sweden because you
guys have the first supposedly
self-proclaimed feminist government
right yes that's what even though as you
could tell when the visitors Aron day
all wars nicob so very feminist indeed
yeah but but the reason I mentioned that
is because I as I said earlier I did
both of your podcast which will link to
below because I want people to see you
guys as hosts but I mentioned the story
to both of you of how the day of the
Stockholm shows it was cold out and I
wanted to get a hack and I went into H&M
which is your is that your great well H
it's like gap here yeah are your
greatest export and I went into H&M and
I was on line to buy the Hat and ice the
guy in front of me young guy probably 20
21 years old says to the cashier this is
the first suit I've ever bought he was
speaking in English so the first food
I've ever bought and and I'm going to
see this Jordan Peterson show tonight
and then the cashier says I'm going to
see the Jordan beaters in show tonight
so I tapped the guy on the shoulder I
turned I said I'm going to see the
Jordan beaters at Joe and he knew who I
was and I just thought it was such an
incredible moment like this young kid
who literally was buying the first suit
of his life so as you just said listen
to a Canadian psychology professor tell
him to sit up straight with his
shoulders tab so can you talk a little
bit about what's happening with either
young people or men or both or something
well we've had there's a problem with
language because what I think they're
trying to do in Sweden have been trying
for my entire life is they're trying to
accomplish gender equity and that's not
the same thing as equality of the sexes
right because you guys have equality of
the sexes in many senses right but that
depends on what you mean with equality
women have the same opportunities in
some cases women even have more
opportunities
when it comes to subsidies for being
pregnant for instance or take the
results maternity leave the results of
the free choices that women make are
though considered a problem yes right so
this is the this is the interesting way
but just to be clear though because what
part of what I said no no no but when
you when you go for gender equity what
you want is well you want the facade
right you want fifty fifty percent fifty
percent here and fifty percent there men
and women it doesn't matter if they're
competent if they want to work there and
we have government bodies regulating
this and trying to we do this from
kindergarten and upwards we encourage
the girls to take up more space and be
less like girls and we encourage the
boys to you know close in words and not
take up as much space to so basically
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to make these kids go against
their biology or whatever they feel is
right because they want it to look
perfect so to be clear it's not just I'm
equal or address right it's not just you
know you should act this way but it ends
up working into how what jobs they
choose because Jordan mentioned this
several times there and a lot of people
talk about this that you because you
guys have had quality for so long
meaning you could do whatever you want
as a man or a woman it turned out that
yes women tend to be nurses more in men
turn out to be engineers more because
women generally are more interested in
people and men happen to be more
interested in things that's just the
nature of reality a gender power is what
you were getting to the social justice
worries don't like that experiment they
don't like the experiment of freedom
Jordan was on a talk show host in Sui or
on a talk show in Sweden where he was
addressing this very topic and he
basically said well you know science
supports that this is the way it happens
in a free country where people can
choose and we had like one of the top
level politicians there and she was well
I don't agree with that and you know I
was just flower I actually made a you
know an episode on my show about that
because like this manages that society
science says this I don't agree with it
okay so what what are you know mystics
yeah but
thing though so the the politician says
that I don't agree with it I don't agree
with what science says I don't agree
with what biology says we all know that
men or women are different it doesn't
make either sex better than the other
just it's just an is but when you hear
that response you think most people just
swallow that and take it I think most
people do that because we're a fiercely
egalitarian very conformist people so
they have been trained for very long to
just accept that form of communication
now we have a you know a government body
the Ministry of equality and I mean just
the name sounds like so totalitarian I
can't you know it's like an 84 totally
and they have the authority to look at
like all companies and other
governmental bodies schools universities
everything everything has to be gender
mainstream and it's all run by women
there are only women working at the so
right so when you do this then as a
private businessman how does that affect
you you know funny thing is like when I
own my YouTube channel started taking
off my business partner he was like okay
what's happening what's going on this
might actually hurt our business
interests and I said well you know if we
start seeing some some you know
disasters happening because of what I'm
saying online we'll have a conversation
and say okay so we tried it for a while
turns out business is booming because
now people are they're you know finding
me just because they see my video so I
want to work with your company mm-hmm so
even though we have all these enemies
now there are some people I wouldn't
want to work with anyway right what
about on the hiring side though I mean
when you're actually hiring people you
have to look at that those immutable
characteristics to figure out who you're
gonna hire well I don't handle the
recruiting anymore personally so I've
kind of removed myself my face from that
a bit I don't think it's much of a
problem because Sweden has a general
problem when it comes to recruiting
talented people we don't have enough of
them we have a lot of people that are
going you know subsidies and various
government programs loads but I mean IT
recruiting you know very smart IT
professionals that's that's generally
very difficult although I find I have
quite a few of them you know these
software guys that are
libertarians so no I don't see it that's
a great problem the you know that
here's another you know thing I'd like
to mention you're not allowed to ask
people anything you want when you hire
them in Sweden so when I first started
out with my company I would ask people
so are you in any unions because I don't
want any unionized people in my
companies and then my HR eventually you
got to stop saying that and Rick it's
illegal you cannot ask them if they're
unionized so now we we have a text and
when we recruit which is kind of like
are you a very collecting a
collectivistic lee minded person this
might not be the place for you I think
it does hurt kids because if you raise
an entire generations of girls telling
them that they are beautiful and we can
strong at the same time and can do no
wrong well you're turning them into
sexist fascists basically and you're
telling all the boys that they are
inherently evil that's and we've been
doing this for a long time now so is
that the part that's particularly
perverse about this so you take a
society you make them equal then at the
same time because you know that humans
are gonna have individual emotions you
keep you keep telling the the male's
that they're evil despite the fact that
you and Sweden have done more for
equality than virtually anybody so it's
all it's really like it's just never
enough because actually as you guys know
what they don't what they want is not
really equality it's and there's no
informative and I've been trying to tell
them that this would be as if someone
came out as gay and you told them no
suppress that right because that's what
you're telling the boys like oh you feel
the need to run around and play football
suppress it and in telling the girls
like you're playing with dolls bad girl
go out and play football now before the
haters get in here and say Oh Aaron flam
doesn't want boys to play with Barbies
you actually are perfectly okay I never
played football I was not the type are
you a huge Barbie collection which
permit a period is a bit much III was
into he-man and Star Wars figurines or
the action yes you call them that to
make them sound more manly but they're
basically dolls I'll show you my claim
yeah
when right here alright let's shift a
little bit because you mentioned
actually that you lived in I believe
you're moving
yes I can say that in Malmo now we hear
a lot about Malmo on a certain side of
the internet where they report on a lot
of bombings and stabbings and all these
weird things coming out of Malmo now we
only hear of this from sort of right but
I would say not just center-right but
more right meaning things outlets in
America and then anyone that reports on
them says that they're racist in their
bigoted and the rest of it you live in
Malmo what happened in Malmo and just
tell me a little bit about the history
of Malmo before you know mom oh it's in
the deep south of Sweden so it's a port
city this is where basically everyone
that's coming to Sweden you know by foot
or by car they will enter across a
bridge and they come into Malmo
so we have a very large number of you
know refugees and so for from the you
know crisis of 2015 and mama is it's
always been a rather poor city you know
used to these the big big ships there
and in the 1980s that all collapsed and
everyone was an alcoholic for a while
then it kind of became slightly better
but it's it's a loss making City and
it's it's been run by socialists for you
know better part of the last hundred
years now over time crime in mama
started to rise uncontrollably and again
coming back to the same topic all the
time you know this concept of being
quiet about what is happening because
it's considered rude to mention the fact
that well we might have a you know a
drug war going on in this city and
that's what we have right now so people
are working very hard at putting out
different kind of representation
statistical representation saying
everything is fine but you know it's
getting harder and harder for them to do
that because everyone knows that we did
not use to have like weekly bomb bombs
going off in the city centre for one
thing and if I can I'd like to sort of
tie this back to a personal experience
you mentioned that time that I was
burglarized and what's really
interesting about that story is not so
much the fact
burglarize but rather the reaction I got
from the media when I wrote about this
from the police is when you ask them
what can I do about this I'll just make
it really short you know I wake up in
the middle of the night you know
somebody's trying to break into our
house I carry my you know my twin girls
upstairs armed myself with a hammer
because I didn't have a gun at home
hammer I'm on the phone with the police
they're trying to you know force entry
through our front door and the police is
there be quiet don't make your presence
known we'll be there shortly
and my neighbor comes home where shared
walkway he scared them off by turning on
the light so they they go away
30 minutes later I'm give I'm giving my
testimony a statement suit to the police
sitting in my kitchen and I asked him at
the end of the interview it's like so
what can I do to protect myself with my
family from this ever happening again
and literally he does this seriously
don't live in this city it is out of
control we cannot control it this was in
2007 you know that year I think I
believe I paid about 12 million in taxes
and I live in a very you know
fashionable part of town as I expect
house it's very nice that's where I
interview yeah I expect a better answer
by the police and them telling me to
leave so I wrote an editorial about this
in you know Sweden's largest
conservative newspaper and told the
story about the work basically what the
policeman told me which I think that
this is the really shocking part you
know the reaction by the local newspaper
in Malmo was they didn't speak to me
they spoke to the paper that took my
editorial and said this is completely
unacceptable what poor taste and
journalistic unprofessionalism that you
should publish an alarmist populistic
texts like this which is drawing the
attention from the people in need this
is a this is a wealthy capitalists and
he's spoiled and you should don't listen
to this alarmism and that really shocked
me because I had journalists attacking
me on Facebook why do you write that why
do you why do you put a text like that
out there yeah so and this was just when
I was starting my youtube channel so
this
and then you got called racist and the
rest of it right racist that fascist
bigoted right-wing nut job you know they
didn't work or yeah but so all this
being said you stayed in Malmo for two
years basis well he's not Jewish yeah I
will get to that but you stayed yeah we
stayed then the crime situation has
escalated so when we finally the straw
that broke the camel's back was the this
summer and I made a video about this it
was so tragic because these drug cartels
were basically fighting it out in Malmo
they they shot a young mother in the
head while she was carrying and I can
hardly speak about this because it
really upsets me to be honest they shot
her at dead in the head while she was
carrying her newborn baby because she
was affiliated with one of the drug
gangs and there was a trial thing going
on this was nine o'clock in the morning
on a public street in one of the most
affluent neighborhoods in the city and
it just it really broke me and I said I
am NOT raising my children in this city
so so now we're looking for a house
outside listen you're on your way out as
the representative of all Jewish people
in sleaze they wouldn't like that at all
I bet you I bet you secretly they would
maybe they wouldn't want who knows
there's to know but but there's only
what about 7,000 Jews left in Sweden is
that right maybe eight I don't know it's
it's it fluctuates nowadays yeah but you
sort of explain what mama used to have a
vibrant Jewish community over around
three thousand four hundred years and by
now there's probably maybe 300 years
left they've all left malmö in the last
few years they go either to Stockholm if
they're young or if they come to America
or Canada or Israel
so they've evacuated the city pretty
much and it has gone so far the two
private individuals donated forty
million of their own money to the Jewish
congregation so that they can manage
security for the 300 individuals left
just for the coming ten years one of
them was done all of zon that you have
interview
on my show and I'm hoping to get him on
your show as well yes but we will talk
about different subjects you talked
about entrepreneurship and I will talk
about he's a massive entrepreneurial
talent again well you'd have to be to
donate 20 million out of your own pocket
for two found fine found Sweden's first
private militia which is basically what
it will become
can you explain sort of so you were
talking about kind of gang violence and
that sort of thing
what can you explain how that's sort of
related to why Jews would be getting out
specifically obviously we've seen this
sort of it's not no problem also we've
had a huge influx of immigration from
poor Middle Eastern and North African
countries where state anti-semitism is
part of everyday life growing up so they
come to us they're still anti-semites
and the Socialists of Sweden being on
Hitler's side until the end of the world
war never dealing with that have been
you know it's low simmering sort of
thing that they've never dealt with and
they have an alliance and they don't
care if the Jews are forced out of the
city that's just yeah we need to mention
that the government is well the Social
Democrats who have been ruling for a
long time they are actively siding with
Palestine in you know in the middle
eastern question yeah and you know the
historical this goes way back but it's
got something to do with Israel being in
cahoots with America and America is the
Great Satan so then because if you're a
socialist being oppressed as a currency
the Palestinians are the more oppressed
so they cite with them but we have you
know the youth organization of the
Social Democratic Party and I'll send
you a video of this you can see it for
yourself when they demonstrate like on
the 1st of May would they have a sort of
a socialist holiday where they celebrate
I don't know whatever socialist
celebrate potato day what are they what
its social itself no first of May's
International Workers day they celebrate
celebrate being poor as now they will
hate me more yeah they sang and this is
on video and last time they did you know
the debate always sing that song
LIHEAP labor palestina labor Palestine
now closer see you nice man I think you
can pick out a couple of words right
there it means celebrate celebrate
celebrate Palestine and crush scientism
yeah and this is this is the socialist
youth organization people yeah it's a
middle class Swedish people yeah and to
me that's an outrage is an outrage they
never speak about this no and the the
former strongman of malmö the Social
Democratic leader in Maria Paula he had
I mean and semitism he has been accused
of being a nun Semite for decades now
but he always denied it and by now they
can't tonight because there is no there
are no Jews left so yeah can you guys
explain a little bit about how the
immigration issue arose that basically
this all started just in the last really
seven years something like that but a
pretty much homogeneous society for
better or worse decided I think but
correct me if I'm wrong I think probably
with good intentions by people that
weren't thinking that much to bring in a
ton of people how many immigrants
roughly have come in over the last
decade you can take this one or if you
take it over a decade the numbers are
always changing because they're playing
around with them so it but it depends on
how you kind of calculate it but it is
it is a bit over a million people so
okay so roughly a tenth of the
population yeah came in let's say in the
last decade from these countries what do
you think the leaders thought exactly it
was gonna happen let's say well
intentioned but do you think maybe I'm
giving them no no let's let's do the
well intention because I like to give
people the benefit of the doubt I think
they were hoping for a a multicultural
Nirvana with you know T Bob's you know
and some belly dancing yeah and that
everyone else a lot of smoked fish guys
are killing it in this game by the way
that is true yeah but other than that I
think the idea is if you live in a
culture that is so homogenous as Sweden
is you cannot think outside the box of
our own culture they don't even perceive
that we have a culture
they probably believe they will become
sweets very quickly when they realize
how right and good we are yes they will
be also didn't happen go yeah so if we
were not to give them the benefit of the
doubt because I also I try not to go to
people's motives and I think the road to
hell is paved with good intentions and I
think a lot of these people think
they're doing the right thing but it'll
but let's go to the non good motive
I think you just wrote a book about it
yeah I mean what what so think these
people thought they were doing or what
do you think they thought was going to
happen just when you change demographics
that much a tenth of a population is a
huge huge huge amount well I think they
won't wanted to him so the social
democrat came into power they actually
lifted up the working class to a much
better living standard and the idea was
as soon as we get them up to
middle-class living standards they will
become true communists and understand
that they need to devote everything to
the struggle what happened in reality
was that they were perfectly fine with
her flat-screen TVs they wanted more
flat-screen TVs and longer vacation time
they didn't want to join a communist
revolution they became in essence
well our equivalent of Republicans I
suppose so they needed new voters in a
sense and they in voted and then they
took in a lot of people into the most
over regulated labour market in the
world and these people second generation
and third generation immigrants they're
not getting into the system they're
keeping them for the ballots they want
their votes and they can they keep them
on subsidies and some of these kids they
see that the system is rigged against
them and they have no choice stable
because of course they will become
gangsters or will go off and fight for
Isis after a while all of them obviously
I think it's important at this point to
remember that the people that came in
you know those individuals it's not
their fault inherently you know they
were invited that I asked about the
intentions and good or bad of the people
that brought them in not these people's
no I'd like to think you know crowds
always go crazy but individuals are much
more reasonable you know and somebody is
you know fleeing a war you know I have
the deepest sympathy yes of course I
would do the same thing
but it is irresponsible if you have a so
regulated labor market and you you take
in more people than you can help it
that's like you were throwing a party
that goes haywire on Facebook everyone's
invited you know I have drinks for 12
people what what did they think that
people were gonna do like what kind of
jobs did they think people were gonna
have or did they immediately say you're
taking care of for a year you know we
hear these stories that the government
wanted to start a camel farm in
Gothenburg but that was one of the one
experiment for some and that's a yeah
that was crazy
I'm sort of racist I'm sort of racist
yeah but no we can't give you a proper
job but we'll give you some subsidies
start a camel farm you should be good at
that and also we have plenty of camels
in Sweden no we don't we have rain
they're truly people come in and as you
said they're often fleeing war you have
sympathies with all these people the
government then says here's some stuff
but you can't have it forever although
they sort of do have it forever but not
just that you can't have it forever it's
a limited amount of stuff right we can't
put you and then you then they can turn
around and say see we're also racist
because we didn't make you millionaires
night one yeah there exactly they get a
flat they get a minimum living subsidy
subsidy but and then they are expected
to vote left and that is what it looks
like if you break down the statistics of
different municipalities and how they
vote I mean in Rose and Gordon Malm it
was like eight seventy to ninety percent
worked it for the Social Democrat or the
left's yes yes I mean they're you know
we have the numbers for all of that but
what's happened is tragically we created
a tremendous segregation yeah well a new
underclass if you will an immigrant
underclass which Sweden never had mhm
and we don't know how to deal with it
and we're also running out of money
because we have the most expensive
welfare system in the world and now
we're trying to deal with it it nobody
knows what to do this is a sort of
dangerous question in a way but I think
these conversations always end up here
which is do you think in a weird way
this then breeds racism yes that good
intentioned people right you mean you
just made it very clear
you have no ill-will towards these
people but then these people come into
these countries they're given these
things they demand more the politicians
use them for votes and then good people
who are not racist but maybe don't have
a lot of time to think about all these
things suddenly start becoming kind of
racist it's just it's just a sad fact of
humanity absolutely and I think it goes
both ways I think the Swedes wanted to
invite poor people from the third world
to come and live in Sweden because they
wanted to feel good themselves but also
they thought everyone would want to
become Swedish of course but then they
get a lot of immigrants and the
immigrants look at the Swedish society
and they're like maybe I'm gonna keep
some of my own culture yeah because I
don't think this is so great
and if you were to sort of and also if
you keep them out of the system and you
never let them in and you stick them in
ghettos of course they will start to
hate you and there's a weird thing that
I think Europe has that America doesn't
have which is that if you were to
assimilate them more sort of push more
of a Swedish culture on them that would
be against Swedish nature in a bizarre
way where America we have a melting pot
here so come here with all of your
traditions and all of those things but
mix into the fabric of America where
Europe has more of a ghettoization
of culture this I think the reason
America can can do this better is
because your country is founded on the
principle of individuality and
individuals whereas Sweden is founded on
the idea of collectivism and that makes
it really hard to break the molds now I
have a good friend who's he's working
he's doing a lot of work with newly
arrived African boys and like the top
question this is Mustafa Perry the the
the question he is most often asked by
these guys it's like how do I make
Swedish friends I don't know they never
will open up I'm never in touch with
them and at the same time I mean this is
like again bringing tears to my eyes
they want to work they want to break
into becoming useful at the same time
sweets will battalion oh no how you
should behave no I couldn't possibly
tell you just beers be yourself yes and
they give nothing away because they
don't understand being so collectivist
like we have a very closed very
complicated culture and if we
want to invite people into our culture
we need to start you know you here we do
it this way this is you know but that is
considered almost racist certainly
socially aggressive to tell people that
well this is how we do things around
here we take off our shoes before we can
come into someone's home that is quite
unique yeah yeah it's awesome the
Japanese although we're more sloppy than
the Japanese I think there are all these
unwritten rules of course there are but
for the longest time Swedes denied that
because it would be racist to admit we
had our own culture can you guys talk a
little bit about how how you
differentiate from some of the other
Nordic countries because as I said we
always point to the Nordic countries but
Sweden is the one that we really focus
on but it sounds from what I could tell
and I did visit Denmark and I visited
Finland and at a couple other places
Denmark doesn't seem to have the
problems as much as well they did up
until they had those cartoonists
scandals and then they sort of
understood what it was all about
if you can't criticize Mohammed that's
basically blasphemy laws and no modern
Western state would stand for that I've
had farming Rosa obviously you know is
there yes the habla sure of the cartoons
and I mean what an absolute brave person
and someone who is you know now has to
live unfortunately with a lifetime of
security who the idea that this is a
racist or bigoted is so patently absurd
yes it was a Muslim author who was
trying to find a cartoonist that sparked
the whole idea in the first place yeah I
know he was trying to help I mean it
yeah but I also think culturally over
hundreds of years Sweden and Denmark
they've fought for supremacy in
Scandinavia and they sort of culturally
define themselves in opposition to each
other so Danes are more they're closer
to the continent they're more vivacious
they like to call on a shovel a shovel
actually in Danish it's a spade a spade
but that would be wrong here I think so
and Sweden is completely the opposite
don't don't rock the boat well you know
if you look look at this from a
historical perspective I think it's it's
fair to say that Sweden was the Nordic
superpower in
1600s yes we'd basically taken over the
rest of the Scandinavian countries and
then we kind of gradually lost control
of that we gave Norway independence and
Denmark broke off but the languages and
the culture is fairly similar but
Sweden's attitude has remained as the
stuck-up Big Brother that always knows
best I mean we are very arrogant culture
if I can say so myself I think it's it's
pretty clear that the Danes for instance
they think we're stuck up and we're just
playing wrong and now that we are you
know we've gone a bad way no it's right
now we're moving on yeah it is so
embarrassing to admit it so now it's
like you know a situation where you know
I have to maintain maintain that I'm
doing it this way because it's too
embarrassing to come out to say okay
that was a big mistake I'm sorry you
know the Danes are putting up border
controls against Sweden now yes we just
want your problems with bombs you have
in Mama to be exported into Copenhagen
right but if you talk about those
problems exactly no a lot of trouble no
yeah the response when when you know
Denmark did that the response from
Swedish politicians was like oh this is
completely alarmist but we we welcomed
the Danes to do what they would hate
please so they were just saving face
yeah but it's I mean for Sweden which is
one of the like most advanced IT service
countries in the world to have to deal
with the fact that people are saying we
have to have border controls to you guys
because there's so much craziness
spilling into our country this analogy
of that you mentioned of sort of a
Hollywood facade on all this so as I
said it looks too good on the outside I
really do think is part of the problem
it looks too good from the outside
everyone looks too good and and
everyone's clothes look too neat a new
impress than great and everyone looks
sort of too healthy and I guess that's
not in every city but it's at least
what's exported we have your origin
eugenics eugenic programs that took care
of that that's probably a whole other
show that's when you get guys like this
yeah look at the perfection is there
anything else that we didn't hit on sort
of in the real sort of meat of all of
this house it has it been an hour order
I'm sorry it's because he talks it's a
lot of none but I've been here before so
yeah yeah no I think we're fine for now
aren't we yeah well it was it - anything
else you was asking you guys because no
I think it was great yes this was as
much of a recap of well I guess we
should talk a little bit about IKEA or
some of your he ordered a drink the
other night when we were to dinner and
they made him put it together himself
revenge the idea furniture they know you
ordered it what like an Irish Coffee I
wanted an Irish Coffee for dessert yeah
and it came in parts yeah you know I got
a cup of coffee and what's in it no
whiskey yeah don't worry cognac yeah
Bailey's three separate classes so I had
to build it then yeah you know tell the
serving staff they were they were
getting even and we were lacking the
cream yes so just like an Ikea always
you know we yeah yeah but you did have
your allen wrench with you and you were
able to put it together very quickly we
met it works
we barely worse if I do have a lot of
Ikea here I'll give you a tour of my
IKEA you know in LA we have the world's
biggest IKEA did you know that no I did
not in Burbank maybe we may have to go
there this afternoon world's biggest if
I went with two Swedes no they wouldn't
give you the Royal Treatment rusty no no
no they probably well with you two I
probably would be kicked out yeah it has
been a pleasure chatting with you guys
you know what because you are
professional podcast YouTube hosts I'm
gonna let you guys pimp yourselves out
directly to camera Henrik right over
there thank you Dave yeah
what if you are interested in Europe in
general Sweden specifically you can
check out my channel where I do weekly
commentaries on current issues I do
analysis on economic business finance
that sort of thing with the European I
on it I also do stuff to explain this
for an english-speaking audience I'm
really a businessman so this is more of
a vocation than a profession but for me
but I think it would be interesting for
me to find an english-speaking audience
what's the name of your YouTube channel
my youtube channel if you put in Henrik
J you will find my english-speaking
channel
and from there you can kind of find my
Swedish one if you want more content
it's all subtitled in English so you can
see it but then you really have to be a
sort of Sweden nerd if you want to go
into Swedish interior politics he is a
pro so I really absolutely yeah I know
look into the camera oh my god my name
is Aron flam I'm a Swedish comedian and
podcaster the name of my podcast is
deconstructed criticism I have a few
episodes in English I've just finished a
book that I wrote and published myself
in Sweden about the situation the
Western world finds itself in today
because of what happened in the past
there will be an English translation on
my web page Aron flam calm soon enough
thank you well gentlemen I consider us
colleagues now we are in the world that
we exist in but more importantly I
consider us friends we had a great time
the other night and I know this is just
the beginning of things that we'll all
do together yeah follow these guys on
Twitter and on YouTube and all those
good places and get over to Sweden and
visit them you'll take people out oh
yeah I take good care of my guests don't
alright thanks everybody if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our international playlists and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists there all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell